[Musique]
j'assume plus rien écoutez il ya une
activité manuelle que j'ai jamais fait
de ma vie tout simplement parce que si
tu l'as fait unique la vie de quelqu'un
désolé mais c'est vrai la coiffure la
coiffure qui n'a jamais rêvé de couper
des cheveux c'est de faire un petit
dégradé de faire une frange de faire ce
genre de truc alors évidemment on a tous
tenté tôt ou tard un truc avec nos
cheveux dans notre vie nous mêmes de par
nous-mêmes je veux dire mais globalement
on est éclatée et puis ensuite on
préfère payer le coiffeur on est
d'accord moi ma seule expérience que
j'ai vu avec savons c'est une teinture
qui a mal tourné que j'ai directement
une vidéo et s'est coupée des mèches par
ci par là à une époque où ma mère était
trop rating tomber le coiffeur ces boues
pour vous pourquoi je suis jean michel
basique au niveau des cheveux parce que
parce que je n'ai pas pu développer ça
je n'avais pas l'argent pour aller chez
le coiffeur
écoutez moi bien sûr youtube je pensais
pas mais il ya une chimie de tuto pour
apprendre à faire des coupes très
précise ou détail de bach ou bref tout
ce qui est pilosité quoi c'est
impressionnant alors en fait c'est assez
logique que ça va avec la mode du barber
shop qui s'est ré répondu aux us en
france aussi il ya maintenant un vrai
délire autour de sa écoutez je vais
tester j'ai jamais coiffer ça me fait
mourir de rire
j'ai attendu et on croit pas sur cheveux
huit nouveaux ya c'est pas la spa du
liquide vitre c'est juste que j avais
oublié d'acheter cet accessoire donc
j'ai trouvé un truc du ménage que j'ai
vidé j'ai mis de l'eau à la place si ça
pique un peu c'est normal il a mais là
nous allons aujourd'hui pratiquée tout
d'abord sur isabelle et ensuite sur
henry un homme
on va tester sur isabelle une coupe je
crois s'appelle carré plongeant plus
franges et sur henry on va tester le
très célèbre dégradé jules excité là ok
je suis excité comme à chaque fois qu'on
fait une activité manuelle mais d'abord
ici on fait les choses bien tu connais
offre là ça s'est très mal j personnes
s'y attendait hop là dans ce tutoriel
vidéo dédiée aux coiffeurs expérimentés
nous allons observer
ça commence très mal dédié au cou
attendons des 10 aux coiffeurs
expérimentés nous allons observer
comment réaliser une parfaite
distribution des volumes sur une base
qu'avec matin on va sur une sheryfa luna
non c'était ça alors à temps parce que
elle elle parle quand même d'une
longueur là
qui hélas genre d'ailleurs tu regarde
cette vidéo serait génial c'est très
très long je pense qu'il faut faire un
prêt et un prêt découpage pour avoir la
même base que lui il a dans la vidéo ça
y est je suis passé un mois try hard là
en quelques secondes c'est juste en bas
du on y va fâchent
ok j'ai raccourci oh c'est moche ça je
crois faut séparer l'art est là comme ça
là c'est voilà c'est ça pousse voilà
faut suivre l'implantation mon pote
une fois que l'implantation est suivie
c'est quoi ce ne va tout ça
ça sent le produit pour vite je suis
désolé c'est bon là je suis fière
c'est beau je parle beaucoup je n'ai
même pas commencé à la coupe c'est beau
je suis très nerveux respectez moi notre
ligne de séparation se situe à ses hôtes
à l'endroit même où les cheveux ont
toujours tendance à s'aplatir après le
coiffeur un mec je suis désolé mais ton
isabelle là elle a une meilleure
implantation des cheveux que mon
isabelle non mais vraiment chouchou
comment on fait ça mais que je sais même
pas la délimitation est fait on peut
commencer à couper ses parties comment
on fait la zone supérieure étant isolées
vont commencer à couper la zone a en
démêlant les cheveux du bas vers le haut
avec une projection maximum c'est tout
simplement linverse de ce que je viens
faire donc je te remercie que nous
conservons une longueur d'environ 15 cm
écoutons avec la technique de sculpteurs
inverser les gestes successifs repousse
chaque fois les cheveux à la manière
d'un crêpage à huit semaines la salle
isabelle regarder très passerelle
selon l'épaisseur des cheveux plus
complet trop ou non avec un piquetage
avec le sculpteur évasion va tenter avec
ce 8e 10 15 cm on y va
et mesdames avoué en vrai c'est une fois
mais qu'est ce que je pensais mais qu'il
ya un petit côté un peu irrégulier voici
ce que vous devriez obtenir
voilà la hâte en 2 minutes 20 il a fait
tout le tour est là mais on est où là ok
bah écoute et on s'y colle j'ai envie de
vous dire pourquoi dire que je veux du
mal à chaque fois que ce couple de mèche
ça valait isabelle bouge pas
oh mec c'est chaud est-ce que tout se
passait bien
tout va bien tout va bien tout se passe
bien ok et isabelle c'est une
catastrophe
j'ai complètement mal vu il y avait ces
régularités folle attends je vais je
fais deux trois touches et j'arrive vous
êtes rassurés ou pas mesdames quand vous
sentez le souffle de son nez dans votre
nuque et qui fait auquel à l'étape
suivante
nous poursuivons avec cinq nouvelles
zones de travail b c d e et f
j'ai cru qu'ils allaient faire tout
l'alphabet dans la zone b nous
sélectionnons une première partition
verticale les cheveux sont coupées avec
la technique de sculpteurs renversé
alors j'ai la théorie mais la pratique
c'est quoi ces sadiques war commencé au
centre avec une première partition de
cheveux aux sages des voix à faire ça je
les vois faire des fois dans les salons
voilà je m'exclame pour pas grand chose
on les voit faire on s'en fout on paye
île où nous font directement sur nous
que ça c'est la messe verticale je
l'appelle moi elle est horrible au jeu
léché les trouver je vais vous dire
mieux elle est là et maintenant prenez
en compte l'inclinaison de la tête pour
choisir votre angle de coupe et couper
avec la même technique de filage c'est
très dur à c'est très dur je venais
d'acheter préfère que ça à faire ça
c'est beaucoup trop d'eau y est même
répété le même procédé
de l'autre côté
ok pour les cotons je crois je l'est
dans la zone e
nous utilisons des partitions radial une
projection moyenne et un angle de 90
degrés mfg mais voilà voilà pourquoi il
ya des maths au collège mais c'est pour
tous les mecs qui vont devenir coiffeur
derrière on est obligé ça commence à
ressembler à quelque chose
elle joue pas contre mais ça commence à
ressembler à quelque chose rose c'est
beau c'est tellement équilibré on en est
tellement loin et isabelle bon écoutez
on a fait le contour moi je trouve que
ça passe en réalité peut être que je me
voile la face oui évidemment je revois
ce bon le devant rob à saint lô tuto
puisque moi j'ai pas très fan cette
coupe je trouve qu'elle manque de
projection bilatérales au niveau de la
mèche et touche fauve passau surtout
qu'il n'a pas suivi la technique du
quimper multiples enfin bref c'est un
peu un truc d'amateurs à ce qui se passe
donc on va aller sur un autre tu tout
juste poule devant un tuto forges
ok alors à temps déjà il faut que je
libère le chou ça va lui c'est au niveau
du menton que ça va donc c'est ça on va
y aller d'un couple à pouzauges pas on
n'a rien vu venir
[Musique]
ok j'ai
ok c'est fait votre compliqué jusque-là
français gagnera côté f mecs faut être
patient en fait la clé de tous ces trucs
c'est qu'il faut être [ __ ] de passion
[Musique]
tout le monde commet mais une frange
s'te plaît puisque la bla bla bla bla je
te demandes comment enlever une frange
c'est parti mais qu'est ce qui se passe
ça mais pourquoi siro big mac mais
pourquoi sa rubrique ma grâce te plains
mais pourquoi pourquoi sa rubrique non
on dirait moi le matin attentes autant
là je vais faire le mouv des coiffeurs
magique là je sais soit faire faute et
s'épaissir mais faute et s'épaissir j'ai
toujours rêvé d' avance de 6 oh là là là
avec les lamas voyons pas celui là et
quand il le fait lui pas fait recette
déchire ça fait mal ça tu arraches des
cheveux ou alors à l'époque mon coiffeur
était vraiment une grosse merde je sais
pas ok ce parti je vais le pen dans le
mauvais sens tu à l'erreur
[Musique]
je sais bon ben là c'est simple si
c'était une cliente je serais morte
gelée licenciés en fait je sais ce qu'on
va faire mais qu on fait confiance
bah essayer quand même on est dans le
même bateau [ __ ] j'ai plus le choix
mais on va créer une coupe en direct
dans cette vidéo sur sa chaîne youtube
si aujourd'hui on green comme qui va
devenir à la mode je rigole pas l'idée
gens mais ça s'inspire d'un truc a déjà
été vue c'est parti
[Musique]
tu as des savanes en vrai ok c'est pas
parfait genre l'accusé régularité mais
en vrai ça passe c'est pas ouf enfin il
faudrait de la lacc et tout mais s'ils
avaient de la lacc ce serait parfait mec
franchement mais que c'est pas dégueu
quoi il est peut-être un truc que je
vous ai caché à part qu'on en fait je
m'en sortais pas avec l'épaisseur de ses
cheveux
[Musique]
j'ai tout eu le dos je lave mais c'est
pas grave parce que les gens ils te
regardent dans les yeux par exemple en
deuil jamais il voit de dos au pirée mes
impôts des mecs si elles étaient déjà
installés qu'elle te regarde comme ça et
que ses jolis yeux et isabelle
imaginons qu'à lui de la l'académie de
la lacc tout soit bien plaqué là d'un
coup il a belle elle te dit attends je
t'invite inquiète ça me fait plaisir
elle se lève et quand elle pas un mec tu
vois ça moi c'est oui direct frérot
direct bon allez tout le monde dit
bonjour a envie bonjour henry salut à
tous je m'entends pas gérable pour le
monde et le mec qui me tient est un gros
beauf qui se prend pour un ventriloque
ça avait mal à l'aise tout le monde ya
beaucoup de malaises cette vidéo mais
mec démarrer si en même temps je suis
seul à parler à des têtes en plastique
en rien un problème alors lui mec je
vais tout donner je vais là je vais tout
donner je sais qu'il ya des modes et des
mecs qui kiffent sur les mecs aux
cheveux longs et je dois vous dire
j'avoue avec un chignon genre ça fait un
petit steam mais je sais pas comment on
fait un dégradé par contre puisque je
sais c'est qu'il va falloir que laura
consiste de foule ça va mais y'a
vraiment plusieurs couches en fait ça
qui est super dur regardez il ya
vraiment plusieurs couches de cheveux et
là tu vois en raccourcissant la couche
dans au faux pas de raccourci de la
couche qui a derrière quoi sinon je me
retrouve baiser je fais des mouches de
quoi faire mec je suis choqué quand ils
coupent les pointes comme ça là pour
donner de l'effet là je suis un coiffeur
mec
[Musique]
à
on notera marché ça y est qui c'est qui
va voir son petit des gras gras qui a
foi se la péter devant les copains on
atteint une longueur correct ça y est on
peut commencer
regardez up hockey s'est bâtie c'est ma
première ligne avec le battant 2 1
disputé leur fief
moi je la béglaise faux mais voilà comme
je chante souvent la première ligne est
très très très importante
il détermine un peu le flou de votre les
autres dégradés dont kinect ou votre
temps pour la faire ok ok ok aux états
j'ai pas envie de le décevoir
[Musique]
ouais d'accord si c'est une vraie
personne je vais couper l'oreille sans
bon sens
rolala à sa part v ce n'est pas un bruit
pas je peux me rater c'est pas grave
frêche en train de créer un [ __ ] de
hipsters je vous le dis sans fabo
ouverte et là je crée une deuxième ligne
à qui le mans mais seulement auquel à
cette deuxième ligne
[Musique]
je
je suis un des gardes et lestrem et vous
un mec
en fait c'est dommage parce que là j'ai
coupé court alors que c'était là ça
marche pas la coupe qui fait j'arrive
pas à la faire j'ai le droit de me
ramener le frère d'henry et de faire une
coupe à ma sauce tél j'ai une idée grave
cool mais si je le fais je m'en fous je
suis désolé franche de mais là tu vas
pouvoir regarder mais là c'est trop il
ya vraiment un truc style et j'ai failli
tomber à faire mathieu
je vais très bien les flots
mf je vous jure que en train de réussir
à faire un truc là c'est fou parce
espaces
[Musique]
oh la la il estimé ok la barre d'abord
la barre il faut cette barbe faire notre
coup là c'est ça n'a aucun sens
make giga tueries ou pas c'est pas le
mec trop sympa qui tient la porte à
l'entrée du centre commercial
avouez c'est lui mais qu j'ai pas envie
de toucher en fait il est trop bien là
je vois pas pourquoi on n'y toucherait
il est nickel trouvaient pas et je suis
désolé de passif des tutos et d'être de
tête dans mon coin mais c'est trop dur à
suivre en fait regarder 28 minutes 28
minutes pour arriver à ce résultat
évidemment l égard mais entre lui et lui
celui qui paie juin max
il est sur un trépied en métal sur un
tabouret auquel je vous connais le tient
je l'a un jour se maquille vient au
salon il décide de tout changer il en a
marre des cheveux longs ça fait 10 ans
cerulli pécho trop salé trop y en a
marre c'est on le ok pas de souci on lui
ajoute juste la petite nouveauté 2009
akka cours sur les côtés et les mèche
plaquée jusqu'au derrière attend ya
quand même une stricte affaire
[Musique]
voilà le travail est terminé je lui
retire la petite barrette là il fait la
gueule alors je fais le mouv du coiffeur
pour lui faire croire que c'est
maintenant que tout se joue alors
comment je les foires et mg pose la
question suivante mec pourquoi je me
sens invincible freedent fait écouter on
va vivre un grand moment ça va être
aurais je te présente isabelle isabelle
voici en vie ah j'ai oublié henry je te
présente belle lisa je deviens
complètement fou en fait bon écoutez il
est temps de conclure en fait c'est
beaucoup plus dur que ce que j'imaginais
alors je sais que je dis très souvent ça
c'est vraiment dur là j'ai un respect
pour toutes les mamans qui coupe les
cheveux de leurs enfants et qu'ils
réussissent à avoir un truc style est à
l'arrivée
- la mère faisait ça quand j'étais petit
alors qu'elle est pas coiffeuse mais
énorme respect maman c'est hyper
technique c'est hyper dur je vous jure
je regarderai plus jamais à quoi faire
la même manière j'ai fait un tas de la
frite donc je suis assez bon mais mexes
et c'est vraiment dur est en fait les
tutos j'arrivais pas à les suivre mais
c'est juste c'est un suivent à bhl c'est
des schémas géométriques frérot où il
compte l'implantation je n'arrivais même
pas à comprendre la lettre à ce que
c'était en tout cas j'ai adoré c'est un
vrai kif c'est très stressant de couper
des cheveux quand tu le fais pas souvent
hyper stressant parce que tu sais que
chaque coup qu'tu mais c'est un peu
comme tatoué et ben tu peux pas revenir
en arrière et isabelle en a payé les
frais hockey j'adore ces vidéos
activités manuelles parce qu'elle elle
casse beaucoup d'à priori que j'avais
sur beaucoup de choses je me fais
vraiment avoir un respect immense envers
ceux qui arrivent à faire des trucs un
peu avec leurs mains c'est fou j'ai pu
croire que ça allait aller en fera mieux
la prochaine fois c'est comme ça qu'on
fini toutes ces vidéos de façon presque
dix ans en disant qu'on fera mieux
on arrive en plus à parler à l'essai
chao et joyeux noël les poteaux
[Applaudissements]
bon
[Musique]
oh